[Music]
i'm just going in man i i am
so excited for this
i'm beyond i'm beyond excited i just
want to do it man was granted a soul
and with it clarity
on the second day upon earth was planted
an irrevocable poison
a soul-devouring demon
cool
it looks really smooth
nice
this looks better than i thought it
would holy crap
nice
it's clunkier than the rest but a
masterpiece regardless
what was there a cinematic like this for
the original one
whoa
there was okay cool
that dragon looks that dragon looks sick
oh my god
wow
demon souls
so again i've never ever played demon
souls at any point i've played every
other game multiple times
uh except for dark souls 2. um
i don't i've never beaten dark souls 2
just because i it wasn't my it wasn't my
cup of tea we're gonna play that soon
but demon souls i've never played it i
think i saw some gameplay of the remake
at the beginning like right when it came
out like back in 2020
with the ps5 and then i nothing after
that and i've been trying to get a ps5
ever since i saw this was gonna be a
remake and i finally got one
so none of the items are too crazy you
guys are saying ring though should i do
the ring instead of the firebomb we'll
do that i i just want to play i just
wanna play king alant the twelfth
by channeling the power of souls
brought unprecedented prosperity to his
northern kingdom of boletaria
until the colorless deep fog swept
across the land
boletaria was cut off from the outside
world
and those who dared penetrate the deep
fog
never returned the deep fog huh but
valifacts of the royal twin fangs broke
free from the fog and told the world of
politaria's blind
and that a colorless folk had swept in
unleashing terrible what is that thing
the demons hunt down holy [ __ ] claim
their souls
those who lose their souls
lose also their minds
the mad attack the sane and are those
all people down there
valefax also spoke of the enticing power
of the demon souls
each time attacking i don't know why
there isn't subtitles
the demon's own song is invigorated by
the life force
and the power of a mature demon soul is
beyond human imagination
okay spread quickly epic mighty warriors
lured by the possibilities braved the
fisher to breach the accursed land
but none have returned
pure of the twin fangs
little lizard boy in the bottom silent
chief
center bane
whoa
scurver the wanderer i like the vibe of
this so far the sick saint destroyer
with her night girl finland thank you
ludwig and sage for the two months great
room bro i appreciate you dude
you have a heart attack
creeps beyond boletaria's borders
appreciate it
humankind faces a slow
and steady extinction
this seems like of a much higher scale
actually swallow
all lands near and far
so there's a fog that's going to take
over the whole final
a lone warrior who has braved the
painful fog alone
has the land found its savior that's me
baby demons found a new slave
that's me
would you like to play the play the
journey to the nexus what what is this
i'm gonna say yes i don't know what it
is so absolutely yes
am i in the fog here
brave soul who fears not death
ronnie
that sounded just like ronnie
never mind
whoa
so that you may know the old one back to
slumber
the old one
okay so i've also heard that this game
is like crazy easy
okay
okay
this runs smooth as hell bro oh my god
okay same there
bruh
this looks so good
this no cap looks better than elden ring
so to summarize this all there is a fog
and he wants to kill everything that's
that is what i got out of that yep
okay i have a guard button can i jump
nope no jumping guys
oh hello
can i two-hand
i absolutely can two hand oh [ __ ] hi
what the hell
right out of the way
okay yeah
we're fat rolling a bit
sir stop it
can i backstab
that answers that question wow the
lighting in this is unbelievable hi
buddy i'm gonna two-hand you
nice trout
just like all the hollowed and dark
souls won swing your sword around wildly
and you will probably hit okay so how do
i heal like what is this half moon grass
noble
lotus
crescent moon grass
okay so that heals me a little bit so
i'm looking for grass in this game
okay bro like whoa this looks so good
holy [ __ ]
that's
okay
okay
bro this game looks so incredibly good
i'm gonna say that a million times bro
can i parry
calm down
that guy's dead as hell
dead as hell
okay my guy is fat
down bro
oh i just punched him
i'm trying to parry i'm really
attempting it
there it is
guys
a bonfire
oh an arch stone
oh i didn't think it would teleport me
forlorn outpost
strong attack
right
[Music]
that guy's a bit beefier than the other
ones
okay
demon souls ps3 is fugly
yeah i've seen gameplay of that and i
was like
this is
i mean we haven't even gone outside yet
like we're still in kind of like
little
little tunnels bro
nice roll
trying to parry
i don't know their attacks
there it is
[Music]
look at these animations dude the sound
effects are really crisp
okay i'm gonna two-hand this guy
okay he gets staggered pretty easy
oops
like it feels
it feels [ __ ] heavy bro it feels good
we got a shield boy here okay
throw that shield up dog
look at the blue effect coming out of
their helmet
what's she going to do
nothing
trash can
keep holding that shield up bro
see how it does
just keep holding that shield yeah
that did you a lot of good there buddy
i'm gonna smoke some weed that's how we
heal in this game
excellent
dear dead kid
in your trash at the game bro
nice nice shot yep
oh i can't holy crap i kicked him off
the [ __ ] ledge nice
okay
yo
strong attack you're dead
just infinitely better at the game than
all these people
no wonder i'm the chosen one
half moon grass what is that compared to
the crescent moon grass
i have quite literally never seen a game
look this good at least in these areas
that looks real good
yeah i know i'm still fat rolling it's
fine
the asylum demon hey
what a cutie
jiggly ass
what the hell
guys got some booty bro
hold on fam we're taking our pants off
oh he smacked me with this he backhanded
me
this
[Music]
frames
yeah we had to take our pants off for
this one
he pretty much has two attacks
i like the music
how's the osc in this game
okay
[Music]
that that is about my luck right there
he had no help
i was supposed to die
let strength be granted so the world
might be mended what is this
soul of the lost withdrawn from its
vessel
[Music]
let strength be granted so the world
might be mended
fire keeper so the world might be men
i'm gonna keep saying soul stuff
or dark souls stuff
[Music]
whoa
this is the nexus
it holds together the northern land of
boletaria you guys are all saying mommy
must must be the fire keeper yeah quit
the nexus
cool the five archstones will guide you
to the outer lands feet
you have died and the nexus has
imprisoned your soul you cannot escape
the nexus however by capturing demons
souls
you can reclaim your cur
cor purport
corporeal body
that's how you say that so is this like
firelink shrine why do i have half my
health
uh oh
okay i noticed a line is there and it
doesn't do anything
who are you
well you slipped through the fissure too
did you
oh remind me to turn on subtitles
or to save this land and be remembered
as a hero
freaking guy at the beginning laughing
at me again
try one of course stones
now go
that is why you came is it not
to this accursed politaria
boratalia
whoa like lot a lot more cinematics than
this
are these all elden rings look at this
these look like the elden
okay
wow
i don't think i've seen a game better
than this guys
for real
like uh
graphics wise this looks
very impressive andre
you knew here
are you here for my
services the name's baldwin not andre
just an ordinary blacksmith repair all
okay
good to know
uh
i don't want to upgrade anything yet i
don't know how long i'm gonna have this
for
what do i need to upgrade
three hard stone shards so we're looking
for hard stone sharks you come back
alive i need your business
okay let me turn on
subtities really quick nexus look at the
the mouth animations on these guys
and daughter phil
licked him
to the demons look look at his facial
animations this is amazing i would be
worthless in battle
at the very least
i hope to lend my assistance to you
brave
slayers of demons
that mustache is happy
there's so many more cinematics in this
game already than eldon ring i love it
oh that's a that's a dragon boy
oh he has a bunch of people in his mouth
that's great good enough
each of the archstones takes you to a
different world
i like that okay
neat storage is very important really
okay
gotta turn around and look behind you no
matter what
look at that
late moon grass
does still don't know what that does
guys
no estes get your blood borne ready
so i got a farm grass
why do i have half health right now
crescent moon grass see we're already
farming grass
unknown warrior soul okay
so i'm assuming that's like a poppy boy
i can pop it
and then we get souls for it
nice
you basically don't have a real body
is that why i'm all glowy and weird like
a ghosty boy
you're done
you're done you can stop now you're done
yeah i turned on the webcam
i figured you guys would want my facial
reactions because i've never played this
game before i mean i don't know how many
times i've said it already but this game
looks [ __ ] wicked good
okay um don't go down there that's
pretty clear you have half health
because you are a ghost you may want to
stay a ghost
but i have half health why would i want
to be a ghosty boy
stop it
get some help
[Music]
i'm dead
you're dead
well you know i got a bunch of grass my
guy i knew
that they were high when they made these
games i knew it
this is where it all started so it only
makes sense
okay you calm down i kind of want a
shield
i might go back to the shield boys this
game is so
smooth bro
it feels amazing
like clunkier than the other games
obviously
but it feels good
demon souls was powered by weed
bloodborne is powered by heroin
i can see that it's better than dark
souls 2 though
okay we're still gonna play dark souls 2
but
i'm too excited not to play this game
and we wanted to go in order so
okay they're really big on firebombs in
this area
which
if i know souls games it's telling me
something about the firebombs right
like why are they using so many
firebombs here
see
see stop throwing [ __ ] at me oh i didn't
even see this guy
it doesn't hurt you somebody else is
throwing fire at me
you are
no
i'm fine okay we got about a bunch of
bad boys right here
yeah i ain't gonna cap i can't see
owned i love that i have no pants
calm down sir calm down
dying while in ghostly boyform doesn't
change the world tendency to being
darker
you generally want to keep world
tendency to be as light as possible wait
what like legitimately darker
you're dead
oh my god the fire effects are
over the top
i love it
like you really the the sound effects
really
make you feel like you're hitting
something
it's very clean
changes by your actions when you kill
phantoms or invaders and bosses your
world tendency rises
but i'm always at half health oh god
hey see there there it is there we go
that's how you get the item you go oh
a new sword
bastard sword does 95 damage okay a
little little bigger sword
you get used to half health okay
yeah this does way more damage
wait why is this game so much like
prettier than
elderly don't get me wrong like elden
ring is gorgeous
i mean it's an open world game it's hard
to make everything look amazing
you sir need to calm down
thank you
i believe i am involutaria yes
what are you guarding
hey
i freaking hurt bro
[Music]
get some grass eat some grass
we are in trouble with this guy right
now
[Music]
that's a big hit
coming in
no i want the item okay we're good
uh-oh
they think i haven't played these games
before bro
as i get hit by it immediately
they're giving me a lot of firebombs
and i'm starting to understand why
they're showing me something right there
as well
there are no checkpoints in this game
you have to do permanent progression
through shortcuts
really
okay
i like it
oh
i should have had a fire bomb ready
there i could have threw it at the
barrels
that guy's stupid
oh good they did it to themselves
excellent
you got a little contraption here for
the lever
paul the leather crunk
the cling ring
less hp reduction when in soul form i'm
throwing that [ __ ] on like why wouldn't
i throw that [ __ ] on
yeah see now i got three quarters health
very nice
oh heck yeah
from software smokes weed when they make
when they make these games 100
100 they're high when they make this
stuff bro
i'm loving the atmosphere here
this guy looks a little different than
the other oh
okay
nevermind he was weak
oh god
not a time to eat grass
i'm trying to poke them
very nice this looks breakable
we we gotta upgrade stamina
in case you didn't know the ring gives
you 75 health 75 help with the ring jake
the ring gives you 75
um
i got that i got that from all the
people who told me that so thank you
thank you everybody
okay
okay
unnecessary but sure
nice
i'm gonna drop down
it only hurt a little bit i shouldn't
have done it
i am not in a good spot
okay we're in a better spot now
wow
i am loving the combat in this game like
it's so
it hits
oh my god
double hit
stay right there
just like that
i would qualify the combat as thick i
would mckendree
it's been telling me to use these the
entire time
yeet
i thought there would be more
more there
i really did
i shouldn't be here this is like kind of
scary
oh [ __ ]
cool
oh
okay this guy wanted help
are you
actually friendly my thanks for your
brave rescue no problem strava of
boletaria can i have your sword and your
shield of my gratitude
your sword
this guy
this guy gives me a [ __ ] telescope
for helping his ass okay bye
thanks man i can see better now
appreciate it get ready to walk and talk
where did he go
oh my man still over here he's kind of
ghosty too now i take my leave
there is something i must do
okay bye
[Music]
excellent hey oh you good dog i got you
you seem to be having a hard time
he's still stuck
i got you bro
i want to see what he does like what if
i keep following him does he like go
somewhere
wait wait
don't walk over there
i don't want to accidentally kill him or
anything
very nice where did he go again
my man's disappeared
didn't even say thank you gives me a
[ __ ] telescope and he thinks that's
all he needs to do
no problem
that'd be cool though
some more half moon grass i can only
have max 20 though
almost went right back into that
bye bye
whoa
kinda oh okay this is bad
the bows curved
this could be bad okay here we go
you're bad at your job
you're quite quite mad at your job
whoa look at this
looks so [ __ ] good dude
what is that
now
i hear a dragon over there
oh my god
[Applause]
okay
okay i think the dragon's gone
i don't know why i
talked okay he peaced out it's a lot of
people bro
there he is oh [ __ ]
what is he doing
okay
let me smoke some weed
oh my god
okay i'm booking it we're going
never mind
never mind to that plan
nice try though
okay
just go
just go
go boys i don't care about that item oh
go go go
go go
okay
oh a contraption
i wasn't expecting a cutscene
a face you're all in as a streamer now
yeah i guess
oh that opened the main gate at the
beginning
the [ __ ] is that
all right well that looked like a boss
to me
[Applause]
i got jumped
i need my grass
i just got jumped in an alleyway dog oh
my god that scared me
what is this
i can't see
it's a slug
okay i'm throwing fire at you
ow
[ __ ] you
fire works really well guys
okay first boss i think
bay phalanx
oh it's just a bunch of these guys
well they're weak to fire so
very weak to fire
we got a little green boy in the middle
it doesn't get hurt
i'm hurting them now
ow
[Music]
i'm just going in i'm going in boys
nice
i'm out of fire bombs though that might
be a problem that might be a
problem what is this thing
just a little [ __ ] boy
that's what it is
well heavy attack uh-huh
music's really good
okay we got more spiri boys coming in
i'm gonna heal up here
we've almost got him though
let me get behind this booty
haven't died yet bro try not to spoil
but
why but trust me you should always
return to the nexus and suicide after
you defeat a boss explain to me again
what's wrong with me being a human
i forget what you guys said if you die
in human form your world tendency goes
down
oh so it it just gets real hard huh do i
need to talk to mommy with the with the
feet
whoa
i'm loving all the like little cut
scenes in this
okay
feet
why is she got calm on her eyes
you can make your play through really
annoying if you do not suicide
i mean all right i'll i'll do yeah i
mean you guys know what's going on i've
never played this game before so i have
no idea
the monumental will explain the nexus to
thee
okay
the monumental
put stuff you don't use in storage
you can only carry so much
oh
okay
wow
this is the best looking game i've ever
seen
like no cab
[Music]
are these dead kids
what the [ __ ]
oh
that freaked me out
hi
we have long awaited you
slayer of demons
why don't you why doesn't your mouth
move
hey i found him that's him i found him
hey you said it would take
20
minutes i wish to tell you
once that took like two minutes bro
what happened did i break it
even distant past
under benevolent rule the world was
united owing to the soul arts
until
a lust for power caused the awakening
the [ __ ] is that
across the land seat a colorless deep
fog and the world faced extinction
at the hands of the demons
thanks be
we were able to lull the old one back to
its slumber
yet only after the loss of innumerable
souls
and most of them
why does this feel like a greater scale
than elven rank of what lands still
remains just the way they're telling it
to me you know we entrusted six leaders
with six precious arch stones okay one
to the king that's the one i just went
to right
boletaria
one to the king of the boroughs
underground
right
one to the wise queen of the great ivory
tower
okay
one to the chieftain of lost and
ill-fortuned souls that one looks like a
[ __ ] bird
one to the shaman of the tempest
worshipping shadowman looks like a mummy
and the last to the great giants of the
northern lands and that one looks like a
bug i don't like bugs the arch stones
were placed in
we became monumentals
he's the only monumental left
cool
by the power of the monumental the four
sealed art stones have been unlocked
now it is your turn
hoggers
you must love the old one back to its
slumber
and seal it away that big thing
i gotta fight that big thing if not
a deep fog will absorb all that we know
have you the strength to bear this
burden
i can say no
what happens if i say no though
what what what what happens does the
game end and the world dies by the fog
it's like
i'm good it's not me bro it's not me dog
of course i accept the mission yes
we are fortunate indeed just instinct
credits huh
now
go forward you miss out on a race
[Music]
it's what
the old one has big titties
is that what i just heard i can't get
over how pretty it is man like maybe i'm
saying that too many times or you're all
just agreeing with me as i say it a
million times but this is the best
looking game i've ever seen eyestones
briefly connect
defused worlds
should you lose your physical form
remember the eyestone
the maiden in black manipulate souls
with inhuman prowess her strength allows
her to aid slayers of demons why does
miyazaki make all these fire keepers
blind
you notice that
like she's not even a fire keeper but
all the fire keepers in the other games
are blind too like their eyes are
covered
seek soul power
okay we're getting that to 15.
we'll get strength next
okay so you guys think i should go up
top and and jump off and
go into soul form correct okay this
seems high enough yay
you died
oh the lord's path
let me go here again
i'm getting bloodborne vibes right here
i don't know why though
hey you could stop you know
i don't like this i'm running
i don't like it in
here this game looks really
really really good
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] we gotta run again guys go go go
nope go back go back immediately
now we go now we go
i'm picking up the item
i think we got time
i think we're fine i'm gonna no we no we
are not oh baby
not again not again not again not again
even close
where's my souls though there are so
many different ways for me to go oh [ __ ]
nice job
very impressive the way you flung that
sword around randomly like an idiot
that's bad at the game
i was i was hoping there would be dogs
[Applause]
okay it looks like he starts his fire
attack right there
now we go
i'm not picking this [ __ ] up
i learn
i
i learned
i learned baby
leave me alone
okay we're good
[Applause]
so not every fog gate is a boss fight
just like dark souls one
that answers that question boys keep
running just keep going
just keep swimming swim and swim just
keep swimming swimming
i don't know what i'm doing
this this is not not how i wanted to go
you back it up
i am not gonna [ __ ] around with the dogs
oh [ __ ]
jesus why are you here
oh we meet again fancy that got his
mouth you have all the same [ __ ] from
before bro ooh a claymore
6 000
souls that's a lot
i got you this time you [ __ ]
i really do
oh you can heal
now you're dead though now you're dead
i'd really rather not die here again
okay we're both smoking weed right in
front of each other
see how it is
looks like my weeds a little bit better
bro
looks like that hits a little bit
stronger my guy
lizard
kill it
kill it with fire
give me my twinkle tits
this lizard is so much prettier
large hard stone dude
all right let's see what we got going on
in here
ew what the hell was that thing
that's a big boy oh [ __ ]
let me get rid of all these bow boys
get rid of the bow boy
this guy's got literal lasers
boom
dead
he looks really cool though
that guy's dead no shot he lives
this might have been a mistake
it was almost a mistake
we don't make mistakes though
that's the difference
all right let's go fight this guy
i don't know how to fight him but we're
gonna fight
that hurt
a lot
are you telling me this guy lived
nah he did
[Music]
okay
let me get some tankles
hit them tankles
they're glowing little glowy boy tangles
okay that hurt a little bit that's all
right
okay that hurt that hurt a lot actually
let me heal up
this reminds me of the giant
stomps on my head all day
all right
i'm just staying by the cankles guys
not doing a lot of damage
oh that just insta killed me huh oh my
god
i just have no idea what he's gonna do
hello can i get up
let me get in that dick
oh yeah
okay that hurt
i literally couldn't move i'm staggered
get out of the way
i'm gonna back up now
okay
nice let's go for the head
bonk
bonk
bonk
your little backstep i hate it
i don't like that i i literally can't do
anything about that
yeah i don't want to get insta killed
here
[Music]
this is not good
we got to get him down now
let's get it
okay
no don't do this to me bro let me get up
come on
get up in that head
[Music]
wow
not bad
not bad
we died one time
smoked a lot of weed on that attempt
though
smoked a lot of weed
no we can afford the sword
should we go get the sword
wait okay so if i fall into my death
here will my souls be on beyond a blood
stain that's right here you will have a
blood stain yes okay thank you
nice
this
is actually extremely fun like i wasn't
expecting to have this much fun
with uh the first iteration of the souls
games
here it is
nice
um but this is like freaking great bro
give me my claymore sir
what'll it be then this guy called me
poor like 10 minutes ago
play more but you guys this is really
good right i'm gonna take your word for
it so let me upgrade me
i will touch whatever you want me to
touch
ether
me
that's what we want right there
sorry oh she
she's playing with her toes she's so
cute now seek us the power of the soul
no i like that
okay claymore boom
[Music]
we can double it up
oh i only have two
i thought i had four i mean i did buy a
ps5 just to play this game to be totally
honest with you
a thick colorless fog holds you back
only those who have slain in archdemon
may pass beyond this point you gotta
explore the other worlds should we just
go in order just go on the next one in
order
okay
whoa this is totally different whoa
best looking game i've ever seen to date
who are you
hello there you look insane
souls i trade fine goods for souls he's
got heart stones i need two of those
ayo give me two of those dog
there we go
i i love getting
sticky white slime
i love that kind of stuff are they
non-hostile
these guys look cool
not non-high style
strong
fake his health
now
hey they're not attacking me so
i'm cool with that let's see how a
backstab goes
they still take a lot of hits dude what
the hell is that
no not again not again
run away
it's the fat man
i swear to god bro like
all of these games are just giant sexual
references
i'm dead i'm dead it's over
i think this is an area we just run
through right i'm i'm getting the vibes
of like just run
don't [ __ ] around
you know
i like cut scenes
yep i think this is a run
oh we got a fog door
it's a boss
hell no
why do these stairs lead down to
lava
okay i can see again
where the heck are we little wheelie boy
ah is this our shortcut okay
nice
i want that oh
everything's fine guys
that could have gone
i could have gone south pretty quick
oh my god this is not good
can i get some dogs in the chat
what the [ __ ] was that hitbox
oh god
[ __ ] jump scares in this game man
i made the deal with you to leave you
alone if you leave me alone
we're just owning the fat roll right now
good time to heal forgot about that
guy i was waiting again
that's an excellent hitbox
you're creepy and weird
oh
what a dodge
what incredible timing
that is not
not at all what i wanted to do
did i did i did i did i did
oh we got a tourney boy
get stuck in an animation [ __ ]
you can't hit me when i'm in an
animation
yeah i think you guys can see it fine it
might just be my monitor
they should have card called it dark
souls
you're right
ah my hand i hit the microphone
oh did i make that area not lava anymore
these are all explosive barrels
explode these for me dawg
what what are these hitboxes
is that an attack at any kind
when he's rubbing his belly
well that's that's a cool ass way to die
nice oh i got his leggings
i'm seeing a lot of spider webbing right
now
and i don't like it spider stone shard
how many different shards are there
you okay this game is beautiful i'm
struggling right now however
okey dokey then
oh
okay don't heal directly in front of it
got it
that seems to hurt it
dude that's a good time to heal i don't
know
i just got hit directly by three of
those things that's that's not good
am i [ __ ]
okay it stops
i've barely gotten any hit on this thing
right now
i i don't i don't know
this thing is scary
get back down here
this is bad
this this is not good
i've been webbed
nice nice combo oh god run run run
run
okay this is hard this is quite hard
get up my guy
i need to run
my fat roll is getting me killed right
now isn't it
[Music]
i don't know what this does
he doing
why am i so bad at dodging these
fireballs
wait did i
how do you know you're stuck in the
fireball or in the in the webbing
i was just running what the [ __ ] is
happening
oh i don't like this awesome
that was big that was good
i can't i can't be fat rolling
the fat rolling is 100 getting me killed
there
every day of the week
okay
i gotta go
i'm frustrated i am tilted
holy [ __ ] who told me this game was easy
this game is not easy at all or at least
this level isn't easy holy [ __ ]